اذا المشاهدين شكرا لخالد انا ميسون عزام
واحييكم ونكمل معا هذه التغطيه لا هدنه في
السودان لاقتتال مستمر وان خفت وطقته
والدعوات للتهدئه من الداخل وايضا من
الخارج لم تلقى لدى العسكريين اذانا صاغيه
ولان من يسيطر على الخرطوم يسيطر على
الحرب تتركز العمليات العسكريه في العاصمه
المثلثه والقياده العسكريه للجيش السوداني
التي تضم او كانت تضم وزاره الدفاع وهي
تعتبر الهدف الابرز لكلا الطرفين اهلا بكم
في ساعه جديده من تغطيتنا لحرب لا منتصر
في السودان
الله اكبر هدنه هشه لا اثر لها على الارض
فاصوات اطلاق النيران ودوي الانفجارات
سمعت باستمرار في مناطق مختلفه من الخرطوم
وتحديدا حول مقر الجيش والقصر الجمهوري
سلسله الادانات بمسؤوليه خلقها لا زالت
متبادله بين الاطراف المتنازعه ليقذف كل
منهم كره الاتهام في ملعب الاخر رغم
الجهود الامميه والدوليه المكثفه
الطرفان المتقاتلان لا يعطيان الانطباع
بانهما يريدان وساطه من اجل السلام بينهما
على الفور ما كنت افعله في اليومين
الماضيين هو محاوله التوسط في توقف انساني
لمده ثلاث ساعات في اليوم
الجيش السودانيين فمسؤوليه عن الهدنه واكد
في بيان له ان قوات الدعم السريع لم تلتزم
بها وهاجمت مواقع استراتيجيه من محيط
المطار ومبنى القياده العامه
السيطره على هذه المواقع تعد انتصارا
كبيرا قد يحسم بقيه المعارك في المواقع
الاخرى وفقا لخبراء
وبسبب اهميته القصوى حصن الجيش مركز
القياده من الجهتين الشماليه والغربيه لكن
المعارك اشتدت في الجهتين الجنوبيه
والشرقيه المقابلتين لمطار الخرطوم
قوات الدعم السريع وجهت بدورها ايضا
اتهامات مماثله لقوات الجيش بمخالفه
للقانون الدولي الانساني وقواعد الاشتباك
وخرق الهدنه المتفق عليها بوساطه دوليه
وتبقى الاتهامات متبادله وسط تضارب كبير
في الروايات بين الجانبين سلطان العربيه
[موسيقى]
مزيد معنا من الخرطوم وراس العربيه سالم
الهاشمي اهلا بك سالم باخر التطورات
الميدانيه تفضل
تطورات البريدانيه حتى الان هو موضوع
الهدنه هذا اخر ما ثم يعني في هذا الملف
نوافق عليه الدعم السريع ولم يرد الجيش
السوداني عن موضوع هذه الهدنه بالنسبه
للامور على الارض هناك اشتباكات منذ فجر
اليوم استمرت هذه الاشتراكات حتى قبل نصف
ساعه من الان تقريبا لكنها كانت متقطعه في
ساعات النهار في منتصف النهار وكانت في
اول الفجر في اول النهار ايضا كانت مشتده
لمناطق مختلفه من الخرطوم
انظلمان هي الاقل حده بحري ايضا توجد بها
الشباكات ولكن في الخرطوم كانت اعلى
درجاتها في محيط القياده العامه للجيش
وكذلك في مشاريع الغابه في اقصى غرب
الخرطوم وكذلك في منطقه جبرا ايضا هذه
مناطق اشتباكات وفي بري كذلك وفي اطراف
شارع الستين وكل المقر
التي هي المقر مقر الدعم السريع بشكل عام
ربما هذه هي ابرز المستجدات طبعا نحن
نشاهد صور خاصه بالعربيه من قلب العاصمه
وتحديدا
قرب المقر مقر القياده العسكريه حيث ذكرت
ان هناك كان اشتباكات نشاهد الدخان لازال
يتصاعد وان خفت حدته وبهذا الاطار كان
هناك معلومات تتحدث عن انه الاشتباكات
تجددت الان
ذكرت انه المعلومات التي قدمتها قبل نصف
ساعه من الان ولكن كيف هو الوضع في هذه
اللحظات وفي انباء تتحدث عن ان هناك
اشتباكات قريبه من منزل حماتي
في منطقه جبره وايضا لديه
نعم بالنظر لهذه القضيه قضيه العائلات
هناك مثلا كان هناك فيديو انتشر للمفتشه
العام للقوات المسلحه الفريق مبارك كوتي
وهو الذي قبض عليه من المقبض عليه من قوات
الدعم السريع او قوات الدعم السريع تقول
انه هو موالي لها وهناك العديد من الانماء
المتضاربه حول هذا الموضوع كان له فيديو
تم نشره اليوم يتحدث فيه عن تعامل قوات
الدعم السريع معهم وعن وعن تفاصيل هذا
الامر كثير من المراقبين لهذا الفيديو
تحدثوا على ان هذا هو فيه نوع من اخذ
الرهائن
بعائلاتهم وانه لا يستبعد ان يكون المفتش
العامل الجيش تم اجباره بعائلته بتفاصيل
كهذه لاجباره على ان يقول هذا الامر وبذلك
تكون هي كارت ضغط تمارسه قوات الدعم
السريع على الجيش السوداني باستخدام الاسر
وباستخدام الاسير واسرته ايضا وهذا ايضا
هو يعتبر خرق في القوانين الدولية ولكن
الوصول الى عائلات القيادات الموجوده الى
اي حد هو سهل بالنسبه لهم وهل لنا ان نعرف
الان الصوره
كصوره واضحه حول حجم انتشارهم ومن يسيطر
على ماذا في هذا الوقت تحديدا
نعم حجم انتشار قوات الدعم السريع في
مناطق مختلفه من الخرطوم في مناطق مختلفه
من الخرطوم اي في شوارع بعينها وهناك
ارتكازات لقوات الدعم السريع تتمركز فيها
هذه الارتكازات يعني ان تكون تغلق الشوارع
تماما في هذه المناطق التي تتمركز فيها
قوات الدعم السريع وهي في مناطق القريبه
من معسكرات الدعم السريع بالرغم من ان
الهدنه لم تنجح تم احباطها ولكن ذكرت انه
الاشتباكات كانت متقطعه ما بين الاشتباك
والاخر هل استطاع الناس التحرك هل الهدف
الرئيس من اي هدنه وهو الجانب الانساني
على الاقل كان هناك في امكانيه لانجاحه في
بعض الفترات او لا
موضوع الدعم الاقصد موضوع القضائي
الانسانيه
والممرات الانسانيه التي يطالب بها من
يطالبون بالهدنه هي صعب تطبيقها بدون هدنه
هذه الممرات الان في الاوقات المتقطعه
اصلا منذ ان بدات هذه الحرب حتى الان بعد
العصر مباشره تنشط الحركه قليلا ويبدا
الناس في الخروج حتى في ظل الاشتباكات
العنيفه كذلك هذا لان المواطنين في هذه
اللحظات يقولون احتياج ماس بان يذهبوا
لشراء بعض الحاجات المهمه من بعض البقالات
التي تعمل وهناك بقالات لا تعمل كذلك هناك
اسواق مغلقه بالكامل لكن يخرجون مثلا لجلب
الثلج مثلا للمياه البارده لان هناك مشكله
في الكهرباء ايضا هناك مشكله في المياه
كذلك يقرروا للخروج لجلب مياه الشرب كذلك
ايضا يضرون للخروج كذلك لجلب الخبز وهنا
نشير ايضا الرغيف فيه
مشكله في الامداد امداد الدقيق لهذه
الافران التي تعمل ان هناك افران ايضا لا
تعمل الافران التي تعمل بها صفوف طويله
جدا فبسبب الشحف الامداد بالنسبه للدقيق
هذا الامر كله يتطلب اولا لفتح بعض الطرق
من اجل ان تصل امدادات المعدله الغذائيه
وحتى الامدادات الطبيه كذلك نعم من
الخرطوم مراسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه المعلومات
العربيه والحدث في هذا اليوم الاربعاء
التاسع عشر من ابريل لعام 2023 داخل قاعده
مروي الجويه وداخل مطار مروي الدولي
[موسيقى]
وايضا معنا من الخرطوم حيدر احمد المسؤول
الاعلامي في هيئه مياه الخرطوم اهلا بك
استاذ حيدر اسمحلي ان تعطينا فكره اولا
بدايه عن الازمه المائيه في الخرطوم
تحديدا بصوره عامه وطبعا في ظل الوضع
الحالي المتازم
شكرا
حقيقه
الوضع في محطات المياه كما تعلمين اختي
في السودان
ولايه
بها عدد من المحطات النيليه هذه المحطات
لاسباب متعدده اسباب فنيه تعلق بالكهرباء
واسباب تتعلق بمركز عناصر الدعم السريع في
بعض المحطات الان يمكن ان نقول ان المحطات
في محطات عاده الخدمه بنسبه
60% محطه نور العاتل للخدمه اليوم
لاعاده الخدمه وه
سنحاول العوده الى ضيفي طبعا من الخرطوم
الاستاذ
احمد المسؤول الاعلامي في هيئه مياه
الخرطوم بعد قليل ولكن الان حتى
نعود ونتصل به ونقوم بالاتصال به ننقل لكم
هذه الصور المباشره من الخرطوم طبعا هناك
دخان يتصاعد
وهنا من مقر القياده العسكريه وايضا من
صور من المطار
وادي العوده مشاهدينا الى ضيفي من الخرطوم
حيدر احمد المسؤول الاعلامي في ايات مياه
الخرطوم اهلا بك مجددا كنت قد تحدثت عن
عوده 60% من عمل بعض المحطات
بالنسبه لمحطات المياه وطبعا تحدثت ايضا
عن المشاكل المتعلقه بتوقف عمل البعض
الاخر تفضل
نعم
المحطات بالنسبه 60%
هناك كانت في اسباب اسباب فنيه متعلقه
بالطياره الكهربائي ادى الى احق في
المحطات وايضا اسباب تتعلق بتمركز بعض
عناصر الدعم السريع في بعض المحطات
الان عاده محطه جبل الاولياء جنوب التي
كانت متوقفه بسبب عطل كهربائي واعاده محطه
المقرن الى العمل قبل قليل هذه المحطه كان
فيها مشاكل كهربائيه وكان فيها كان في
تمركز عناصر الدعم السريع في منطقه
المحطه هناك
محطه كبيره في محطه بحري لم تعود الى
الخدمه نسبه
لوجوده في في ظل في ظل
القصف المدفعي
سيد حيدر او انه غياب اليد العامله لا
يمكن تشغيلها
هي لم تصدق لكن القذايف
يعني احدثت بعض المشاكل في ال في في
المحطه حتى السكن الملحق بالمحطه تعرض
لاضرار كبيره جدا غرفه في غرفه غرفه
التحكم الداخليه ايضا تعرضت لقذيفه هو
استه مباشر لكن النتيجه القصف العشوائي
هذا الوضع ادى الى ان يخرج
الفنيين والمهندسين من المحطه حفاظ على
ارواحهم
وبالتالي الان عندما نقول عاده 60% من
المحطات الى العمل نحن نغطي اي مناطق
واعداد من الناس وماذا عن البقيه وكيف
يمكن تعويض هذا النقص بالمياه لهم
كبيره جدا تبذل من قبل
المهندسين والعمال في هيئه مياه الخرطوم
حتى تصل يصل الامداد حط عود المحطات الى
الخدمه بكاملتها الطاقات القصوى وهناك
جهود مع ايضا متصله مع الدفاع المدني حتى
يصل الامداد الماء حتى يصل يعني تناكر
المياه الى المناطق المتضرره مناطق الشحنه
الظروف الامنيه يمكن ان تصل المياه لاكبر
عدد من المواطنين في مناطق الولايه
المختلفه او حتى تصل او يتم تشغيل كل شيء
ما هو او كيف يمكن تعويض هذه المياه
للمواطنين هل من مساعدات على الارض تحركات
على الارض لدعمهم ام انه المياه مقطوعه
كليا الان على بعض المناطق
هي المحطات التي عادت للخدمه يمكن ان تغطي
جزء كبير جدا من من المناطق المضره لكن
يعطي كلمه
المناطق المتضرره حتى يصل الامداد المائي
لهذه المناطق يحتاج الى وقت لانه المحطه
بعد ما تشتغل الخطوط الناقله للمياه تحتاج
الى
الى اكثر من سته سبعه ساعات حتى يصل
الامداد المواطن لكن على الارض هناك جهود
كبيره جدا تقوم بها الهيئه بالتنسيق مع
الدفاع المدني حتى تصل لادوات او الاليات
اليات
الدفاع المدني الى المناطق اللي بتعاني من
شيح المياه وذكرت انه في عناصر من الدعم
السريع تتمركز ببعض المحطات وهو الذي ادى
الى توقفها هل من اتصالات دوليه كونه ان
هذه المحطات تعتبر اعيان مدنيه وبالتالي
لا يحق للعسكر التواجد فيها او لا
طبعا هذه المحطات
بمحطات وايه محطات
لخدمه المياه وخدمه المياه معروف يعني اذا
انقطع سيكون الوضع كارثي وبالتالي يعني
دعواتنا انه تلا هذه القوات من هذه
المحطات يعني حتى تشتغل محطات وتقدم خدمه
المياه للمواطن
الجهود المبذوره الان يعني هناك نداءات من
هنا وهناك حتى انه يعني يسمح لعمال
ومهندسين والفنيين بدخول المحطات وتشغيله
لانه اذا تعاملت تعامله القوات المسلحه مع
مع هذه العناصر الموجوده او المركزه من
القحطات سوف نجد محطات
تكلف تكلفتها باهظه جدا يعني محطه تكلف
اكثر من 80 مليون دولار لا يمكن ان نفقد
محطه 80 مليون دولار
وي
مكن ان ننزل جه
ود حتى نعالج المشكله يعني من الخصوم حيدر
احمد المسؤول الاعلامي في هيئه مياه
الخرطوم شكرا جزيلا لك
طبعا مشاهدينا في نشره سابقه مع العربيه
حضر سكرتير نقابه اطباء السودان من ان
اعداد النازحين جراء الاقتتال الداخلي في
السودان ترتفع مطالبا المتحاربين من
الطرفين بعدم المساس بالمواطنين والكوادر
الطبيه نتابعه نتابع عمليات نزوح كبيره من
الخرطوم هنا
ونؤكد ونجدد طلبا لطرفي الصراع بعدم
المساس بالمواطنين وعدم تعريض حياتهم
للخطر وعدم تعرضهم لاي عنف في طريقهم الى
اهاليهم في الولايات ما تابعناه وما راجع
عن معلومات خطيره نرجو ان لا تتكرروا ايضا
محافظه على ارواحهم كذلك نطالب بتامين
الكوادر الطبيه وفتح مسارات امنه لها
سكرتير نقابه اطباء السودان الدكتور عطيه
عبد الله لافته الى ان الاوضاع الانسانيه
سيئه للغايه في السودان عموما وعلى وجه
الخصوص في ولايه الخرطوم نتابع الوضع
الانساني سيء للغايه في السودان عموما
وعلى وجه الخصوص ولاده الخرطوم اؤكد لك ان
39 مستشفى مستشفى الكبير قدر نعول عليهم
كثيرا توقف تماما جزء منهم داخل الخرطوم
وجزء خارج الخرطوم ايضا
نقص الامدادات الطبيه والمعينات وكذلك
الغذاءات يشكل هاجس كبير تم اخلاء عدد من
المستشفيات في من قلب الخرطوم لانعدام
الامن فيها لذلك نحن نجدد طلبا لطرفي
الصراع لوقف هذه الحرب العباسيه فورا وفتح
مجالات ومسارات امنه لخروج الجرحى
والمصابين وتوصيل المعينات الانسانيه
للمستشفيات
المزيد من الخرطوم الطاهر ساتي رئيس تحرير
صحيفه اليوم التالي اهلا بك استاذ الطاهر
اي معلومات جديده متوفره لديت حول
التطورات الميدانيه والسياسيه ايضا
حتى الان
لا يوجد تجديد الهدوء في الخطوط انت ايش
قدوم بعد
المعارك التي كانت
عنيفه جدا صباح اليوم
التي شاركها بدايه الازمه
استخدمت فيها كل الاسلحه
الثقيله والمتوسطه والخفيفه
لفتره طويله وفي مواقع مختلفه محيط
القياده وحيا المطار ومحيط الغطس
البحري وهي الاماكن التي تتمركز فيها
قوات الدعم السريع
وايضا لها وجود
متجوز في بعض الاحيان
في الامر
بعض البعد عن دمرت القوات المسلحه مواقع
هذه القوات ومعسكراتها
اصبحت هذه القوات بشكل خطرا على المواطنين
وذلك بممارسه عمليات الله المسلح
والاستجاد والسرقه
في احياء الطرطوم
بعرضهم
[موسيقى]
مساهمه في طرف الهدنه كما تعلمين الهدنه
بحاجه الى الطرفين ولكننا الهدنه التي
وافقت عليها
مشروطه بعدم التحرك هذه القوات متواتمها
بالنسبه للوضع الميداني وذكرت انه هادئ
دعنا نتحدث على المستوى السياسي البعثات
الدبلوماسيه في السودان تقول يجب على
القاده العسكريين بدء حوار عاجل الى اي حد
فيه هناك اجواء تشير الى ذلك خاصه في
الظلم ما ذكرته في ظل
هذه الهدنه التي لم تنجح ولم نسمع حتى لرد
الجيش السوداني على ما ذكروا الدعم السريع
من موافقته على هدنه جديده
الهدنه الصادقه طالب الجهه قياده خدامه
السريع
ولكنها معزوله عن
ميليشياتها ولذلك لم تلتزم
وربما لم تسمع بها هذه
اصبحت متفرغه
وتتصرف خارج سلطه قيادتها وهل هدنه الطالب
بها
القياده بها ايضا مره اخرى
قياده الدعم
الهدنه السابقه
الامر ان هذه القياده تريد وقف اطلاق
النار لترتب نفسها
انتظر حتى نستمع من الجيش ان كان سيقبل
بهذه الهدنه او لا من الخرطوم الطاهر ساتي
رئيس تحرير صحيفه اليوم التالي شكرا جزيلا
لك
الله اكبر هذه الدبابه امامكم تحرقنا لهم
19/4/2023
الله اكبر مباشر مباشر
الان تاريخ
غنايم قوات الدعم السريع الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
هذا هو اعلنت قوات الدعم السريع نقل
الجنود المصريين الذين كانوا في مطار مروي
عند بدء الاشتباكات الى العاصمه الخرطوم
قالت قوات الدعم السريع ان جميع الجنود
المصريين بخير ويتلقون الرعايه اللازمه
وسيتم تسليمهم متى سنحت الفرصه المناسبه
على كل للمزيد معنا من القاهره الصحفيه
المختصه في الشان الافريقي صباح موسى اهلا
بك سيده صباح بدايه قراءتك لهذه التصريحات
هل هي مطمئنه ام ان هذا النقل من مروي الى
الخرطوم فيه رسالات اخرى
في البدايه تحياتي لحضرتك وتحياتي للساده
المشاهدين بالتاكيد فور اعلان هذا الخبر
اعتقد ان يعني هذا النقل في تقديري من
يعني لابد ان يكون له تخوفات يعني
ان تكون الدعم السريع تخطط الى ان تجعل
الجنود والعساكر المصريين في مرحله يعني
مستقبليه ان طالت الحرب الى ان يكونوا
رهائن بضغط من نوع ما على القاهره يعني
انا يعني لا استشعر الامان في عمليه نقلهم
من مروي الى الخرطوم ابدا اعتقد يعني
الدعم السريعه
ستطول ورق الضغط او دروع بشريه
اعتقد اعتقد ستكون ورقه ضغط في مرحله
مستقبليه قد تكون بها تحييد لمصر قد يكون
لو في ضغوطات دوليه قد اعتقد دي قرايتي
للدعم السريع لانه هو مش يسيب الجنود يعني
تقريبا هؤلاء الجنود مش هيطلق صراحهم
بسهوله يبدو كذلك لكن اعتقد ان القياده
المصريه هي يعني طمانه الدخل المصري بان
الجنود في امان فعلا هم في امان لكن انا
اتوقع انهم في مرحله لاحقه لو فعلا هذا
الحديث صحيح وتم نقلهم للخرطوم اعتقد
سيستخدمون كقروض ضغط في مرحله لاحقه لا
تقديري الشخص المرحله وارايتي طبيعه
الورقه التي يمكن ان تستخدم من خلال
ابقاء هؤلاء الجنود مع مصر والدور المطلوب
من مصر في مثل هذه الحاله
اعتقد ان الحرب لو طالت ستكون لها مراحل
يعني المرحله الان الكل يحاول يناشد
الطرفين بضروره وقف اطلاق النار هي مرحله
مناشدات لكن لو الحرب استمرت اكثر من ذلك
بالتاكيد سيكون هناك طاغي وسيكون هناك
يعني في هناك سيكون هناك طرف يضغى في
الحرب قد تكون عليه ضغوطات قد يكون
المجتمع الدولي صوته اعلى هناك عقوبات قد
تكون مصر طرف في هذه العقوبات من الممكن
ان يلوح الدعم السريع بالجنود المصريين في
مرحله لاحقه اتمنى الا نصل اليها لكن هذه
هي القراءه لانه الدعم السريع عندما
يقولهم في امان انا كل كل بيانات الدعم
السريع حتى الهدنه التي بدات بالامس هو مع
بدايات الهدنه كنا على على الحدث بالامس
وقلت انها فتره اختبار هل بالفعل هناك
اتصالات بين ق الدعم السريع ومجموعات
الدعم السريعه على الارض ايضا قلت ان
عمومنا الممكن ان يكون
الهدنه فرصه لدخول مجموعات من الدعم
السريع من الولايات الى الخرطوم الحرب
تكتيكات كما تعلمي واعتقد انه بالفعل قد
استطاع يعني دخول بعض
القوات من الدعم
السريع من الولايات لتدعيم العاصمه
الخرطوم هنا برده اخشى ما اخشى ان يكون
موضوع الجنود والعساكر المصريين بهذه
الطريقه قد تكون ورقه
يعني كيف يستعملها الدعم السريع في
المرحله المقبله لا استطيع بالتحديد قراءه
ذلك لكن ستكون نعم سنه وننتظر دعينا نتحدث
عن الموقف المصري خاصه انه مصر اعلنت انها
على مسافه واحده من جميع الاطراف هذا
الموقف هو
مره شره بوجود
الجنود مع الدعم السريع او لا
لا مصري دائما في السودان على مسافه واحده
الدوله المصريه منذ بدايه الازمه حتى بعد
الثوره حل المستوى السياسي والمدني كانت
كل الدول سواء دول اقليميه او دوليه على
مستوى الاليه الرباعيه على مستوى الثلاثيه
على مستوى التوريكا الولايات المتحده وكل
الدول التي شاركت لحل الازمه في السودان
كانت دائما القاهره على مسافه واحده لا
تريد ان تقحم نفسها لحساسيه العلاقات مع
الخرطوم كانت دائما تلتزم الصمت لم تشترك
في الرباعيه لم تشترك الاليه هي يعني
منظمات التحدي افريقي
والايجاد والامم المتحده لكن مصر
حتى استشعرت ان هناك خطر واعتقد ان
القاهره عندما اعلنت انه لابد ان تكون
هناك ورشه بالقاهره تضم كل الفرقاء
المدنيين اعتقد ان هناك كانت رؤيا
مستقبليه [__] فيها ان الوضع
المدني الانقسامات المدنيه الموجوده لو
استمرت بهذا الوضع سوف تكون النتيجه التي
نحن بصددها الان ولكن للاسف الشديد بعض
المجموعات المدنيه رفضت هذه المبادره
وقالت انها قطع الطريق على الاتفاق
الاطاري برغم ان مصر وافقت على هذا
الاتفاق الاطاري وكانت تريد لملمه الشتات
المدني الذي لم يعني تستخدمه ككارت ذهبي
لهذه المجموعات المدنيه كان من الممكن ان
يكون الانتقال سلس في السودان ما لم ندركه
كله لا نتركه كله بمعنى حتى لو الاتفاق
المدني لم لو لم يحقق حتى على الاقل 60 او
70% من طموحات القوه المدنيه في السودان
لما وصلنا لما وصلنا اليه الان الان
المعادله صفر يعني لو كنا جلسنا جميعا على
طاوله حوار واحده لكنا الى اتفاق جنبنا
انقسام المقوم المكون العسكري مصر كانت
تستقرا ذلك هو موضوع الجنود المصريين مصر
لو ارادت التدخل اعتقد ان مصر لها تجارب
كثيره من الممكن ان تدخل وتحرك تقدير
الشخصي ليس كلام رسمي تقدير ان مصر تستطيع
ان تحمي جنودها ولكنها هي دائما على مسافه
واحده تتحرك الان بشكل كبير مصر اكثر دوله
كانت تفهم حساسيه الامور في السودان لم
تكن تتدخل لمصالح لديها مصالح نعترف لكن
المصالح مصحوبه بامن قومي مصري كان تحركها
اه من اجل الاستقرار في السودان لان هذا
الوضع الذي نحن بصدده الان لو كان البعض
يتهم مصري بانها السبب فيه الان جميع
الحدود عندما ستفتح
مع هذا الوضع ستفتح الى اي دوله ستفتح الى
مصر كل السود لدينا الان ما يقارب 8 مليون
سوداني او من خمسه لثمانيه مليون سوداني
هل بعد هذه الحرب الان للاصوات
البعض يرى انه مصر يجب ان تكون من ضمن
حلقه التفاوض اذا ما نجحوا بذلك سيده صباح
ابقي معي
للضم الينا الان من باريس الكاتب الصحفي
محمد الاسباط اهلا بك سيدي محمد نتحدث عن
الدور المصري ولكن هذا لا يمنع انه ليست
مصر وحدها التي قررت ان تقف على مسافه
واحده ما بين الاطراف نتحدث حتى عن الدول
الغربيه الولايات المتحده ايضا لم تاخذ
موقف جهه مع دون جهه اخرى وغيرها من الدول
لماذا برايك ذلك
مساء الخير لك
مشاهدي قناتكم والتحيه للزميله صباح موسى
المشهد الان رغم تكامل الادوار يعني دور
الرباعيه الدوليه التي تقودها الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وبريطانيا والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه والامارات والاتحاد
الافريقي ومنظمه ايجاد والضغط الذي يمارسه
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
الضغط الذي يمارسه وزير الخارجيه السعودي
رغم كل ذلك يعني يعني اسفر كل هذا الضغط
على مدى يومين تقريبا عن هدنه هشه
او هدنه هدنه عنوان ولكن بلا تفاصيل
لمده 24 ساعه تم خرقها قبل
حلول ميقاتها بنصف ساعه واستمر الخرق لنحو
ساعتين بعد ذلك بعد حلول الاجل
عاشت الخرطوم حاله من الهدوء ثم عاودت في
منتصف بعض منتصف الليل
القوه الناريه
لتدور الجديد في الخرطوم وحتى الان
بالنسبه للهدنه الجده التي تحدث
عنها يتم يتم
الاستماع الى اي رد من قبل الجيش السوداني
ولكن في ظل هذا المشهد المتازم هل لنا نضع
خارطه لمواقف الدول
وخاصه تلك التي ارادت ان تقف على الحياد
اذا مصحه تعبير منها مصر من هالولايات
المتحده وغيرها كيف تتابع
لا هو طبعا اذا كانت لدى الدول التي يعني
تربطها علاقات وثيقه ومعقده
ولديها كروت ضغط حقيقيه على قائد الانقلاب
عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد الدعم السريع
حمادي تحديدا مصر والامارات العربيه
المتحده والسعوديه اذا كانت لديها اراده
ورغبه حقيقيه
ورؤيه مشتركه لوضع حد لهذه الحرب من
الممكن ان يكون لها تاثير هذه الدول لديها
قدرات ولديها علاقات وهنالك شبكه علاقات
معقده جدا فيها المال وفيها السلاح وفيها
العمل الاستخباراتي وفيها التعاون المشترك
وفيها وبالتالي اعتقد ان ان الضغط حقيقه
حتى هذه اللحظه الضغط الحقيقي ياتي من
وبراءه المحيط الضغط الحقيقي ياتي من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وبريطانيا
والاتحاد الاوروبي هذه الدول تضغط اصدقاء
السودان دول الاقليم ودول اقليم بدورها
تمارس ضغطه على الرجلين ولكن ضغط على
استحياء اذا كانت هذه الدول تمتلك اراده
حقيقيه بمقدورها ان تضع حدد لهذه الحرب او
على الاقل تقدير ان يتم وقف اطلاق نار
موثوق واخف اطلاق النار الموثوق يتطلب
وجود برقابه دوليه
ورقابه اعلام خرائط لحركه
المرضى والمشافي والاسعاف والطعام
والادويه
وجود بروتوكول التزام ببروتوكول لحمايه
المسارات التي يتم الاتفاق عليها وتوجد
رغابه
يعني تقول في نهايه في نهايه الحدودنا
باعداد تقرير عن تنفيذ الهدنه والجهات
التي خلقتها وبالتالي يكون هذا التقرير
موجود امام المنظمات الدوليه بما فعل
الامم المتحده حتى ان اذا اذا تم الاتفاق
على هدنه مقبله لا يجروا ايا من الطرفين
ولكن هذه الهديه هذه الهدنه الحديث عنها
هذه الهدنه الشفويه هي الضمانات التي
دائما يتم الحديث عنها وعن غيابها بهذا
الاطار وربما هذا الذي دفع للهدنه بان يتم
احباطها دعني انتقل للسيده صباح للحديث عن
نقطه التدخل والاوراق الضاغطه طبعا ليس من
مصلحه مصر ان تكون دوله على حدودها لاسيما
السودان بان تكون فيها الفوضى وفيها نزاع
يمكن ان يبدا كاشتباكات مسلحه ليصل الى
حرب اهليه كامله وبالتالي طبيعه الضغوطات
التي يمكن ان تفرض وهل بالفعل هناك نوع من
الاستحياء من المجتمع الدولي بصوره عامه
في فرض
رؤيته اذا ما صح التعبير وهو قادر على ذلك
حتى الدول الاقليميه
طبعا بالنسبه للحديث عن مصر مصر صحيح هي
تقف على مسافه واحده من الفرقاء في
السودان كان هذا واضحا وقت الحوار السلمي
المدني الان لو مصر عندما تتحدث عن انها
لا تريد التدخل الخارجي في شؤون السودان
ليس معناه انها ستقف مكتوفه الايدي وايضا
من الجانب الاخر ليس معناه انها ستتدخل
عسكريا كما يتوقع البعض لديها اتصالات
لديها كروت ضغط بالفعل لو تمت يعني
تربيطات مع بعض الدول التي لها تاثير على
الرجلين في الخرطوم كما ذكر الزميل محمد
اسباط بمعنى السعوديه الامارات ايضا هناك
جنوب السودان دايما اعول عليها للعلاقه
الجيده بين الرئيس الفكر والرجلين بالتالي
من الممكن ان يكون هناك ضغوط من نوع ما
على الرجلين التنازل اللي وقف اطلاق النار
لكن مصر في هذه المرحله الحديث عن مسافه
واحده من لابد ان ينتقل الى موضوع عدم
التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه للسودان حتى
نجنب دول جوار ايضا انها تتدخل في الشؤون
الداخليه لان ذلك من الممكن ان يعني لا
يحل الازمه يعقدها اكثر فاكثر لو تدخل
يعني عنصر دولي مع طرف من الاطراف ضد
الطرف الاخر بالتاكيد العمليه ستكون صعبه
جدا وهتكون مشتبكه وبالتالي سنستمر طويلا
طيب نعم الان هناك بالفعل من له
الحظوه اذا مصحه تعبير على الطرفين كي
يوقف القتال ذكرتي قبل قليل خلال اللقاء
بانه على الارض يبدو ان هناك نوع من
التشرذم بالنسبه للقوات الدعم السريع
والقياده منفصله عن جنودها
وبالتالي هل لازال الوقت لصالح اي امكانيه
للتفاوض والحلول ام انه فات الاوان اذا ما
صح التعبير
الوقت الحالي الحديث عن عوده لحوار اعتقد
من الصعوبه وهذا الحديث نكرره من اول يوم
في الاشتباكات العسكريه طالما ان الطلقه
الاولى خرجت اعتقد ان الامور لان قبل
الاشتباكات العسكريه كانت هناك حوارات
كثيره كثيره كثيره بين الرجلين وبين القوه
المدنيه اخذت وطن وقت طويل الغرف المغلقه
اخذت مارس طويل من الحوار واعتقد ان يعني
نسبه ضئيله منه خرجت للعالم والنسبه
الاكبر لم نعلم عنها شيئا حتى يخرج بهذه
الصوره رجلين كان في السلطه
صديقين لمده اربع سنوات كل منهما ظل للاخر
وفجاه كل منهما يتهم الاخر بالاجرام
وتسليمه للعداله اعتقد ان هذا لم ياتي بين
ليله وضحاها بالتاكيد كان يسبقه حوار طويل
هذا الحوار لم يفضي لشيء كانت هناك ايضا
اتصالات كانت هناك رباعيه وثلاثيه ولكن لم
يفضي الامر افضل الى خروج طلقه
يعني لم اتوقع او لم نستقرا بشكل دقيق الى
اي مدى الى متى ستتوقف هذه الطلقات مره
اخرى لكن في هذا التوقيت العوده الى
الحوار همم على الاقل في هذه الايام
الاولى من الصعوبه الا اذا كان في ضغوط
لدول لها علاقات ومصالح مع الطرفين همم
البرهان واحميتي اعتقد ان الامور من لابد
ان تكون يعني في هذه الايام يعني المجتمع
الدولي يحاول ان يراقب لانه
المعظم كان يتوقع ان هذه الضربه ستكون
خاطفه كل طرف يحاول ان يثبت قوته على
الارض ويعود لكن يبدو اننا بصدد حرب
ستستمر قالها ابي احمد عندما ذهب للتجراي
ستاخذ ساعات واخذنا عامين لا يريد ان يكون
هذا السيناريو يستمر بهذه الطريقه المجتمع
الدولي اتضح له تماما والمجتمع الاقليمي
ان هذه الحرب لن تتوقف يعلنون هدنه
ويوافقون عليها ولم يلتزموا بها هناك قرق
لهذه الهدنه انت لم تتعاملي مع جيشين
نظاميين الان هناك جيش نظامي هناك ميليشيا
للدعم السريع كما ذكرنا بالامس ان
الاتصالات يعني هل هناك تنظيم على مستوى
جيش جيش مهني منظم بين قيادات الدعم
السريع وبين هذا الانتشار في العاصمه
الخرطوم حتى حتى متواجد متوفر بغض النظر
عن طريقته لانه الجيش قال بانه قطع
الاتصالات ما بين القياده
والارض ولكن ابقي معي لانه مدى التزام نعم
وما مدى الالتزام صحيح بس خلينا نحكي عن
في ظل ما يحدث الان نحن تحدث عن انه
الخاسر الاكبر هو
المواطن السوداني وكل من على ارض السودان
بعيدا يعني المدنيين بمعنى اخر لانه
بالتزامن مع هذه الاشتباكات الجاريه هناك
الاهالي يشهدون صعوبه في تلقي المساعدات
طبعا تحت الحصار المفروض عليهم المنظمات
الاغاثيه تعزوا صعوبه نقل المساعدات الى
انعدام الممرات الانسانيه طبعا بالاضافه
الى اغلاق عدد من المشافي اثرى تدمير
بنيتها التحتيه نتابع واعود اليكم
وضع انساني يتفاقم بتفاقم الازمه التي
يشهدها السودان والاسوا هو صعوبه تلبيه
الخدمه الانسانيه والصحيه الاساسيه في خضم
الصراع الدموي الذي تشهده البلاد والذي
ادى بحياتي 185 شخصا واصابه
1800 وفق الامم المتحده اما نقابه اطباء
السودان فقد اعلنت عن 174 حاله وفاه واكثر
من 1200 اصابه حصيله اعتبارها السكان في
الخرطوم اقل من اعداد الضحايا على ارض
الواقع
حصار لايام حرم الاهالي في الخرطوم وما
حولها من معظم الخدمات الاساسيه ما يصعب
تقديم العون على منظمات الاغاثه بحسب
الاتحاد الدولي لجمعيه الصليب الاحمر
والهلال الاحمر والذي اكد على وجود
الامكانات لكن انعدام الممرات الانسانيه
هو ما عرقل الوضع
الحصار تجاوز البر الى الجو ليكون اغلاق
مطار السودان وجميع الاجواء السودانيه حجر
عثره اخرى في وجه المساعدات بحسب صحيفه
الكورديان
ازمه طالت القطاع الصحي ايضا لتكون
المشافي في مرمى النيران فقد اغلقت 39 من
اصل تسعه وخمسين مشفى في الخرطوم ومحيطها
الابواب امام الجرح والمرضى بسبب تضرر
البنيه التحتيه الصحيه وفق النقابه اطباء
السودان
حديقه وضع الانسان وضع كارثه
والنظام الصحي الان يمكننا ان نقول انه
منار تماما يظل تعرض عدد من المستشفيات
للقصف والمباشر وخروجها عن الخدمه
ادانتها منظمه صحه العالميه مسميه اياها
انتهاكا خطيرا معلنه مقتل ثلاثه على الاقل
من العاملين في المجال الصحي بالاضافه
لتوقف عشرات المشافي عن العمل
الهجمات على مرافق الرعايه الصحيه انتهاك
صارخ للقانون الدولي والحق في الصحه ويجب
وقفها على الفور اطباء بلا حدود التي
انشات مشفا في دارفور خلال 48 ساعه
استقبلت ما يقارب 136 جريحا توفي منهم 11
شخصا متاثرين بجراحهم
كما ابدت المنظمات قلقها من نقص المعدات
الطبيه التي قد يودي بحياه المزيد وما زاد
من عبء مهامها اعتراض المقاتلين في
الخرطوم لسيارات الاسعاف التي تنقل الجرحى
او حتى الجثث اذا عمر العربيه
كما ذكرنا قبل قليل السلطات الامنيه
السودانيه قطعت اتصالات الهواتف المحموله
لقيادات الدعم السريع وايضا لحراسهم الخاص
وعدد من الضباط والجنود وفق صحيفات
سودانيه واشارت الصحيفه الى ان قوات الدعم
السريع فقدت في ساعات القتال الاولى
المركز الرئيسي للقياده والسيطره بعد ان
تم تدمير مبنى رئاسه الدعم السريع والذي
[__] احدث شبكات الاتصالات والتجسس
الصحيفه اضافت ان السلطات الامنيه اوقفت
فعاليه مختلف شرائح الاتصالات التي بحوزه
قاده الدعم السريع وافراد حراستهم بمن
فيهم قائد القوات حمتي
واشقائه والمقربين منها ايضا
لا زالت معنا من القاهره الصحفيه المختصه
في الشان الافريقي صباح موسى وايضا من
باريس الكاتب الصحفي محمد الاسباط واشير
الى العواجل الهلال الاحمر يحذر من عواقب
وخيمه اذا انهار النظام الصحي في السودان
اذا
المدني هو الاكثر تضررا بما يحدث الان
استاذ محمد كنا نتحدث عن مكون عسكري ومكون
مدني الان نتحدث عن صراع ما بين هذا
المكون العسكري ماذا عن المكون المدني
استاذه اول حاجه يعني ما ان تطلق اول طلقه
في حرب اي حرب
تصمت او تزاح العمل المدني السياسي هذا
المشهد في السودان منذ السبت 15 ابريل
الطلقه الاولى التي اطلقت في حرب الجنرلين
البرهان وحماتي اطلقت ايضا قذيفه من
السلاح الثقيل على العمليه السياسيه فقط
اود ان اعلق على الحديث عن قطعه الاتصالات
عن عن غاده الدعم السريع لا اعتقد ان يكون
لها اي تاثير كلنا نعلم او غالب الصحفيين
والمتابعين للشان في السودان يعلمون ان
الدعم السريع والجيش ايضا حصل على وسائل
الاتصالات متطوره من اسرائيل وشركات
اسرائيليه طوال الثلاثه سنوات والعامين
الماضيين
ولا اعتقد ان يكون لهذا الامر اي اثر سواء
كان تمكن الجيش من قطع او سحب الشرائح في
الشركات الاتصالات الداخليه او تمكن الدعم
السريع من ضرب ابراج الاتصالات هذه هذا
الامر لن يؤثر ابدا على عمليه اتصال
بالنسبه للقوه العسكريه لانها تتعامل مع
اسرائيل واسرائيل وفرت للرجلين
يعني التقنيات حديثه جدا في الاتصالات
العمليه السياسيه بيقول امتها اطلق اطلق
عليها الرجلين وهذا واحد من يعني واحد من
بعض المحللين يقولون ان واحد من الاسباب
التي عجلت بالحرب بين الرجلين هي اقتراب
استلام المدنيين للحكم وهذا
التحليل لا يخلو من وجعها لانه عندما
اقترب ايضا ميقات تسليم رئاسه مجلس
السياده الى رئيس سياده مدني في اكتوبر
2021 لجا قائد الانقلاب عبد الفتاح
البرهان الى تنفيذ اغلاء اكتوبر وبالتالي
زين الرجلين لا يريدان اي عمليه سياسيه
ولا يرقبان في اي تحول انتقالي بالعكس
تماما عكس ذلك تماما هما هما يظنان في
اعماقهم الدفينه انهما وارثان ورساله
الشرعيان لنظام المعزول عمر البشير ويقيب
عنهما ان هذا النظام غامض ضده ثوره شعبيه
لولا هذه الثوره التي قدم السودانيين كلها
لما ظهر البرهان ولا مشهد السياسي او تصدر
المشهد السياسي ولكن لان الرجلين يفتقران
الى الحساسيه الرجلين في حاله عماء تام
يفتقران الى الحساسيه يفتقران الى الخبره
السياسيه هذين الرجلين لديهم خبره واحده
البرهان لديه خبره في القتل وفي قتل
المدنيين مارسها طوال عشرين عاما في
دارفور عندما كان مسؤولا عن القوات
العسكريه التي العسكريه التي تواجه التمرد
وحميتي ايضا وجاء في خلال مواجهته خبيرها
خلال المواجهته للحركات المتمرده في
دارفور ولهذا الرجلين يعرفان لغه واحده هي
لغه القتل وبالتالي كل الحواس الاخرى وكل
الادوات والاليات الاخرى
رغمات الاخرى معطله لديهم يعني معطله
تماما معهم
وشاركهم السلطه وان كان لفتره من الفترات
قبل الاستلام الكامل للذي كانت
واحده من اكبر واحده من اكبر اخطاء
المكونه المدني ان شارك العسكر العسكر
عاده في اي مكان في الدنيا لا يحكمون في
اي مكان العسكري محل مكانه حراسه الحدود
حراسه الدستور ولكن ارتكبوا خطا في 2019
بهذه الشراكه بهذه الشراكه التي زادت
اطماع العسكريين في السلطه ولكن لا يمنع
انه في تلك الفتره الجيش وقف مع
المتظاهرات مع الثوار وبالتالي كان وجوب
ربما المرحله وجود العسكر في تلك الفتره
ولكن لا يمنع انه انت ترى بانه هذه كانت
خطيئه نسال السيده صباح ان كان للمكون
العسكري الان خيارات اخرى او مستقبل حتى
في حكم السودان
اعتقد ان الحديث الان لابد ان نرى يعني
واحد انتصر وواحد انهزم يعني القصه الان
هل له مستقبل
يعني له نصيب في حكم السودان لابد الان ان
تتوقف البنادق سواء توقفت بضغط دولي او
توقفت لان طرف تغلب على الاخر وقتها
بالطبيعه الحال لو انتصر اعترف على طرف
اعتقد انه هو الذي سيشكل المشهد في
السودان مستقبلا لو حصلت تدخلات اقليميه
ودوليه لتنازل الرجلين وتراجعهما الى
الوراء اعتقد سيكون هناك يعني
رؤى بقى دوليه تتدخل في السودان هل سيكون
لها نصيب القوى المدنيه هل سيكون التحول
الديمقراطي ثالث تحول مدني ام ستكون هناك
لابد من شركات عسكريه هذا المشهد اصبح
ضبابي اكثر فاكثر
الشرق سيده صباح ما بين المكونات باكملها
يعني كنا نتحدث عن مكون عسكري مقابل مدني
وان كان هناك اختلافات بالمواقف بالنسبه
للمكون المدني الان نحن نتحدث عن تعميق
وتجذر المشكله اكثر واكثر في السودان
وهذا هو المخيف يعني بمعنى ان انا من
البدايه كل سيناريو في السودان بداناه
بشراكه مدنيه عسكريه انفضت هذه الشراكه
اصبحت هناك خلافات مدنيه عسكريه بعد ذلك
حصل انقلاب 25 اكتوبر اصبحت هناك خلافات
مدنيه مدنيه واضطرينا الى جميع
السيناريوهات تم تنفيذها
بحذافيرها في السودان حتى وصلنا الى ما
وصلنا اليه الان ويرجع ذلك الى ان كل طرف
عندما يجلس على طاوله التفاوض يريد ان
ياخذ 100% من كل شيء مئه في المئه في هذه
الاجواء الاقليميه في هذه الاجواء
الداخليه في هذه صحيح من يعني من حق كل
طرف ان يطمع لكن ان يرى الامور امامي
منغلقه تماما عليه على الاقل يكسب 60 70%
ومرحله مرحله استراتيجيه دائما التكتيكات
تلعب دورا كبيرا في السودان كل طرف يقول
انه خلاص الاتفاق الايطالي كنا على بعد
ايام بسيطه للتوقيع ولكل هيئه نفسه من هو
رئيس الوزراء من هي الحكومه المدنيه من
والغرف المغلقه لا ننكر ان العسكريين
بالتاكيد في اي مكان لديهم اطماع في
السلطه لكن انا ايضا دائما احمل المكون
المدني هو الذي يعني اعطى لهما هذه الفرصه
اكثر فاكثر كانت اصواتهم خافته بعد الثوره
بعد ذلك استطاعوا الانقسام معهم لو رايتي
حمدتي وهو يتحدث عن
القوى الحريه والتغيير التي يدافع عنها
بعد الاطار لو رايتيه يتحدث بعد ان اخفقت
الوثيقه الدستوريه وكل طرف تحدث بلهجه
عجيبه وهجوم شديده على قوى اعلان الحريه
والتغيير بعد ذلك عاده القاره وقال هذا
الاطار يعني كانت هناك تناقضات كثيره في
السودان سهلت على العسكري ان الكل يريد كل
طيب بالتاكيد فتحت الباب على وايضا فتحت
الثغرات على الفلول النظام السابق ودعيني
واكد لك انها يعني اخطاء المدنيين كانت
كثيره ليس معنى هذا كانت اخطائهم كثيره
وفتحت الباب وكانت لديهم
ذهبيه كثيره لكن اطراف كثيره منهم كانت
تريد كل شيء والان لا تملك اي شيء من
القاهره الصحفيه المختصه في الشان
الافريقي صباح موسى ومن باريس كان معنا
الكاتب الصحفي محمد الاسباط شكرا جزيلا
لكما
تمكن فريق العربيه من الدخول وايضا التجول
ظهر اليوم بمطار مروي الدولي والقاعده
الجويه العسكريه الملحقه بالمطار اظهرت
صور العربيه حجم الضرار الضرر عذرا الذي
لحق بالبنى التحتيه للمطار فضلا عن تدمير
جزء كبير من برج المراقبه بالمطار في وقت
قال فيه الجيش انه بات يسيطر تماما على
مداخل وعلى مخارج وايضا محيط القاعده
والمطار نتابع العربيه والحدث في هذا
اليوم الاربعاء التاسع عشر من ابريل لعام
2023 داخل قاعده مروي الجويه وداخل مطار
مروي الدولي هذا المطار الذي كان مسرحا
لعمليات عسكريه خلال خمسه ايام مضت هو
الان بهذه الوضعيه وبهذه الشاكله بعد
اشتداد العمليات العسكريه والحربيه
والاشتباكات بين قوات الجيش السوداني وبين
قوات الدعم السريع
هذه الصور التي تتابعونها حصريا على
العربيه والحدث لاننا وصلنا الان قبل قليل
الى هذا المطار بعد ان اصبح بسيطره كامله
تحت قياده الجيش السوداني وتحت سيطره
القوات المسلحه السودانيه التي انتشرت عبر
الاليات وعبر المدفعيه وعبر الدبابات
الثقيله هذا هو المطار بوضعيته الراهنه
بعد خمسه ايام من عمليات عسكريه على اشدها
شهدتها هذه المنطقه وهذه القاعده العسكريه
الاستراتيجيه العملياتيه الجويه بشمال
السودان في منطقه مروي طائرات عسكريه حسب
ما نرى الان في الصوره لم تتضرر هنالك بعض
الطائرات تضررت هذا المكان الذي تشاهدونه
الان هو يقدم الخدمات اللوجستيه للطائرات
ايضا تضرر وتاثر بفعل الاشتباكات والضربات
العنيفه التي حدثت في هذه
المنطقه الان هذا المطار وهذا الجزء من
المطار هو حيوي يتعلق بهبوط بقيام
الطائرات التدريبات كانت في هذا المكان
الان القوات المسلحه السودانيه تنتشر في
محيط وفي ارجاء هذا المكان تتمركز في
مختلف الاتجاهات في الاتجاه الشمالي في
الاتجاه الجنوبي وفي الاتجاه الغربي وفي
الاتجاه الشرقي حسب افادات خاصه للعربيه
والحدث بان الجيش السوداني القوات المسلحه
السوداني الان تفرز سيطرتها بالكامل على
كل مداخل ومخارج هذا المطار والقاعده
العملاتيه الجويه هنا في مدينه مروي شمال
السودان يوم الامس دارت اشتباكات عنيفه
على اثرها
غادرت قوات الدعم السريع واضطرت بحسب بيان
للجيش السوداني لمغادره هذه القاعده
العسكريه الجويه العملياتيه شمالا بعدها
مباشره تعاملت
الطيران او تعامل الطيران الجيش السوداني
مع من خرج من هذه القاعده وكبدهم خسائر
فادحه بحسب ايضا مصادر عسكريه الان هذا
المطار بكلياته بكامله في يد الجيش
السوداني ويدى القوات المسلحه من داخل
مطار مروي الدولي ومن داخل القاعده
العسكريه الجويه العملياتيه نزار البغداوي
لقناتي العربيه والحدث
التغطيه حتى هذه الساعه انتهت ولكن مستمره
على راس الساعه مع ليال المشاهدينا ابقوا
معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات